Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of Dim Lighting.
We are in the month of
December in the year 2022.
So it's time to start
reflecting, you know,
on our activities.
And what's one of the most
important activities that we do?
Buy stuff.
No, I just-
Well this has become a tradition.
This has just become a
tradition. It's kind of fun.
It's a good way to look
back at our year to just,
to look at our Amazon purchase histories.
I think this is at least the third year
we've done an it in a row.
Who knows what comes from it.
It's a good way to reflect,
not to just brag on, I mean,
you can see a lot of, you will see-
Brag?
Some of the stuff that I
bought is not, is not braggy.
It just kind of highlights a lot
that I've gone through this year.
Specifically, trying to get my dog
to not poop in the house.
Oh, oh, oh.
You know what, that reminds me?
Oh, you're adding something to your list?
So we each have our own list.
We haven't shared it with each other.
We're gonna share it with
you at the same time,
because this is real, these
conversations are real.
They're not rehearsed.
It's the first time we've ever
talked about these things.
Wouldn't it suck?
If for every episode we
had to rehearse the episode
and then redo it?
That would be so weird.
Especially if you found out
that's what we were doing.
Some people do that.
Well, yeah.
Some people who just
do a podcast, you know.
But we have found a way-
I should hope not.
We have found a way to do the,
and I mean actually it ties
in well with the reason
we're doing this episode.
Because when you do a podcast
that's basically every week
of the year with maybe a couple breaks
and you do other things,
when you come up with
something that fills a spot
in a schedule like,
"Hey, we talked about our
Amazon purchases last year,
that went well, let's do that again."
You always go back to it.
I mean, in one sense,
you do it out of convenience.
Unless you don't like it.
So you can hashtag 'Ear
Biscuits' and let us know
if this should be the last year
we talk about our Amazon purchases.
But we would love a suggestion
for a replacement episode.
188 Ear Pod One!
Ear Pod One!
If you want to yell at us about it.
But why would you replace it
when we can start with
something very exciting
right out of the gate.
Like my most re-che, recent purchase.
Yeah? Re-shent?
Measuring spoons.
Oh!
Look out!
Watch it!
You haven't had measuring spoons?
We did have a bunch of measuring spoons,
but it suddenly got whittled down
to just one: the tablespoon.
And I find myself-
Yeah and when you wanna
measure like a cup,
how many tablespoons do you need in a cup?
Well, no, it's not the larger
than tablespoon measurements
that are a problem because I
still have like a, you know,
like a Pyrex cup measuring kind of thing.
It's the teaspoons and
the half tablespoons.
Of course, you know, I'd have
zero need for these things.
So I'm just like,
we have 'em,-
Well, interestingly-
But I don't use 'em.
Well of course, you don't bake, but-
I mean, if we run outta
spoons, I might eat with one.
But here's the thing, it's not for baking
cause I don't really bake.
It's for supplements and
smoothie type things.
Right? Because I've been
doing a number of things like,
this doesn't make it taste good,
but I put olive oil, straight
olive oil in my smoothie.
Really?
Long story, I'll probably
talk about it at some point.
But I did this program
where they test your blood-
Oh, a long story that ends in
you just putting olive
oil in your smoothie?
Let's stop everything. I
want to hear that right now.
It essentially is, cause you know what,
I think there should be
a sponsor at some point,
so I'm not gonna say who it was,
but basically they do a blood test
and then it gives you all these biomarkers
and then it gives you lifestyle changes
and nutritional changes
in order to address
some of your deficiencies or whatever.
And so I've got high LDL
and so one of the ways to lower that,
and maybe some other things
that are wrong with me
is more Omega-3s.
You can get that in olive oil.
So it was just add two tea
tablespoons of olive oil
to your diet every day, you know?
Hmm.
So it's like, okay, I'll do that.
And I cook with olive oil,
but I also put it in my smoothie
now, cause why not, right?
Just get it all in there.
But you didn't have
the right spoon.
Well, but then I also, I
take creatine every day.
And so that's supposed to be a 500 gram,
which is approximately two teaspoons,
which is approximately two
thirds of a tablespoon.
You take, you know, I do think we have to
have an at least a part of an episode
where you go through all
this stuff that you're taking
because I don't like to
think about this stuff
and I think there's some of it
that I might need to be taking.
And I'm just like, you take so much.
I would just like for you
to step through it and why,
but I don't want you to do it right now
because, well, you know,
I'm in holiday mode.
Well, let me just say also
that there are much better podcasts
for going through the supplements
that you should be taking.
But I can give you my
rationale at some point,
which is just gonna be more-
Listening to another podcast?
Watered down rationale of another podcast.
Okay. All right.
But, so I've got this
tablespoon has become
me eyeballing what a third
and what two thirds of the-
this is just, it's not working for me.
And also I'm like, what
happened to that thing?
At one point we had the whole key chain
of measuring spoons and then it just,
once they separated it was like
they all went into different
places in the house.
And now all I got is a tablespoon.
So I feel somewhat recentered
because that has come and
now I have the whole thing.
Let me make you feel better because I know
you chalk this up to your family's M.O.,
of you guys lose things
and your drawers are chaos,
you know?
You know, open any drawer in our house
and it is so perfect.
I love it and I love that
Christie and I are the same,
but I'll make you feel better
or at least I don't know what it will do.
But I will tell you, I have
noticed that our main spoons,
they've been disappearing.
I actually had a
conversation with Christie
a couple weeks ago, I was
like, "Where are our spoons?"
The normal spoons, the ones
that I use for everything.
And she's like, "I don't know,
but I have been noticing
that they're dwindling."
I was like, "I think we
need to buy more spoons."
And then it kind of-
Sounds like a kid issue.
It kind of came down to Lincoln.
It's gotta be, I was
gonna say it's Lincoln.
I think he's...
I think he's throwing away the spoons
cause he takes all these
dishes to his room.
And then I've learned,
whenever I'm about to run the dishwasher,
I've developed this habit
right before I hit start on that puppy.
I usually do it late at night,
like right before I go to bed.
Nothing makes me happier than waking up
to clean dishes in the dishwasher.
Well a lot of things make me happy.
But nothing like that.
Nothing like that.
So I've started making
the trip into his bedroom
and scouring the place
for bowls and spoons.
But apparently, like a rat nest.
There's gonna be some nest somewhere
that's just made out of spoons in his room
that I haven't found yet.
Oh, that's definitely what's happening.
Does he grab a spoon full of peanut butter
and walk to his room?
He eats... From what I can
tell what's left in the bowl,
it's ramen.
He's eating ramen with a spoon?
I think he has a fork and a spoon.
Okay, well we need to talk to
him about that first of all.
Since you're start-
You want me to move on?
Since you're starting with
your most recent purchase,
I'll start with ours
and pretty much all of these are mine,
except this one is a collective one.
But I did approve it,
because Christie knew that
it could lead to some sort of a conflict.
Vickerman, seven and a half
foot tall, silver tinsel fur,
artificial Christmas tree.
Unlit, faux silver.
She was like, "I'm gonna
get another Christmas tree.
Do you want a a gold
one, a silver one? Or?"
I think she was like, "It
also comes in orange."
I'm like, "What the hell?"
I don't want a damn orange Christmas tree.
She was like, "Well I'm
just throwing it out there.
Your mom's coming in for
Christmas this year."
Maybe bronze.
"And I want it to be as
festive as possible."
I'm like, "You know
what, that's a good idea
and I don't have an opinion on this.
If you wanna go with-
So where's the-
Apparently she chose silver.
The other Christmas tree
is where right now?
Usually?
Well it's in the garage at
the Creative House because-
No, no, no.
I'm saying when you, this is-
In a box.
You're gonna have one in the living room
and one in the family area?
Is that the plan?
Yeah, I think maybe it'll be
in the foyer, the entrance.
You know, and then just-
We have one across from
the piano in the main room
when you first walk in the house,
that's where we put it
and we have to shimmy a
bunch of trees around,
you know, Christie and
her plants and trees.
All that has to-
There's a whole musical chairs of,
we gotta move this tree
in order to put the Christmas tree here
and then we gotta move what-
And so then the tree goes
where the big plant is
and then the big plant goes
where the smaller plant is.
I have to move eight different things
in a strategic round robin
in order to make room
for the Christmas tree.
And now I think we're putting
another one in the back.
You've opened, just so you understand,
you have opened a door to a place
that I would never want to go.
Yeah.
My wife tries to get me
to go there all the time.
Multiple trees?
I don't understand why
and I don't wanna sound like a, you know,
like a guy from like 1986 comedian
complaining about his wife.
So just take this with a grain of salt.
But I just feel like my wife-
Say Jesse, let's start
doing that first of all.
Why?
Because the my wife thing in 2023.
Got to stop.
No, but I'm
playing the guy from 1986 right now.
Okay.
My wife Jesse. Is that a good compromise?
For this year, yeah.
I'm also doing it so that
when you export clips,
you know that I'm talking
about my wife and not,
who's Jesse?
I could be talking about
Jesse Helms, remember him?
Oh God.
Not really, yes.
North Carolina Senator,
let's leave it at that.
I appreciate, first of all,
I mean she is so, and both of our wives,
so very much skilled at
making a space so welcoming.
If it's supposed to be festive,
it's gonna be festive in a
tasteful and compelling way
that makes everyone who comes
over to your house feel great,
makes you feel great
when you're in the space.
But for some reason, I can't
accept the extra effort
and inconvenience that comes
from the decorative process.
So when you talk about
a second tree?
Because you know
it's going to be on you.
And a second tree.
I know, dude.
That's why she-
That's twice the amount-
Christie was asking me
what color it should be,
but I think she was really just giving,
fair warning, there's a whole other tree.
We are one hundred-
Oh, she manipulated you by asking you
what color it should be.
The wrong question.
Yeah, and she threw the mom card.
Your mom's coming in this year
and your mom's love trees.
Yeah, we need to do it up for my mom,
but yeah, this is gonna be on me.
Oh, so you, you fell for it immediately?
I freaking fell for it.
I'm not saying I would, I
would've gone along with it.
I fell for it.
But I would've acknowledged
that I was being manipulated.
And the thing I didn't do
and I didn't realize it until
I freaking read it out loud.
Which of these words is the trigger word?
Seven feet.
Actually no.
Unlit.
Unfreaking lit.
What the hell Christie?
My wife.
What are you doing buying an unlit tree?
I think I have to go,
I have to click right
now, cancel this order
and then reorder a lit
freaking silver tree.
Did you not discuss that part?
I totally forgot because that
was the big breakthrough,
was we bought the lit tree and now-
You know me, man, I
bought a lit tree one time
and then we still had
to put more lights on it
because part of it didn't work.
So, I mean, that's a-
And we can't even store it at my house.
Like I gotta go over to
the Creative House garage,
get the tree that we
bought a couple years ago
cause it won't fit in my
garage without being seen.
And I refuse to have things
stored that are seen.
Yep. Don't even get into it.
That are seen?
I like things-
I have freaking cabinets
and everything's behind
a freaking cabinet.
I gotta freaking light this tree?
All right, well I feel for you.
We do have four trees in
our house, I will say that,
already, but there's only
one that's normal sized.
I think I, you know what?
The other three are small.
I was getting excited.
I almost said-
So I have fallen victim to this.
And we're gonna get a
live tree again this year.
Yeah, we get a live tree every year.
My mom's coming.
One live tree and then three
small fake trees, yeah.
I mean it's just a runaround.
How about this one? Try this on for size.
Coarse sea salt.
Now...
Is this for bathing?
No, but some of these purchases-
Is it like a scrub?
I actually noticed in looking
at my list of purchases
this year, which were, you know-
Most of them are not-
I have a couple of big ticket items.
Okay.
But most of 'em are like core sea salt,
which probably costs 10 bucks.
A big thing of it.
Is based on something that I learned,
a lesson that I learned that
now I am applying in life.
Well, can I guess?
So you said it wasn't a scrub,
does it go in your mouth still?
You're not gonna guess it.
Coarse?
I could give you an hour
and you wouldn't get to it.
Is it for cleaning?
Because that's what I would use it for.
Okay. Yes, but do you
know what it's for clean?
What it's for clean?
What it's cleaning, what it
cleans, what I use it for.
Cement stains?
No.
In your driveway?
I'm not sure how entertaining
this guessing game's gonna be.
Okay what?
Cast iron pans.
Okay yeah.
So a big revelation this year for me
was the embracing of cooking on cast iron.
You know, you hear people
talk about it all the time
and then we had one because you've always,
everybody's got one and then
you start cooking with it
and you're like, I don't like-
What? You can't clean it, what?
You can't use soap? What, what?
It just seems like an
inconvenience, right?
Yeah.
And everybody says that they're non-stick,
but actually they're not,
everything sticks to 'em.
So this year, I don't know what it was,
but I just, you know what it
was, it was freaking TikTok.
That's what it was.
It was being unable to
avoid people giving you tips
on how to do things correctly.
And so somebody talking about
a cast iron pan in a TikTok
and being like, if you
just do it like this,
it will become the best
pan that you've ever owned.
And so I was like, okay,
screw it, I'll do it.
And I did it and it is the best pan.
And now I have a bigger one.
And then one of the
things that I figured out
through another TikTok,
not the same TikTok,
is that a great way when
you're done cooking with it
to clean it, is you kind of, you know,
you kind of get everything
you can out of there
and then you just put a bunch
of coarse sea salt in there,
heat it up really hot and
just take a paper towel
and just sort of move
it all around in there
and it gets everything.
And then you just take that
under the sink with some water
and you just boom, boom, boom.
And then you put more
oil on it, heat it up,
and then leave it there and
it becomes super seasoned.
And it's just been revolutionary for me.
The interesting thing about this
is that I not only know all of this,
but I have personally experienced it.
We are experiencing a strange intersection
between the two of us.
A convergence?
Yeah, because I, you know, I don't cook.
I've already established
that with the spoons
and everything else I've talked
about ever about cooking,
but, it could have been
on TikTok for me as well,
I'm a cleaner,
and I saw a TikTok where
somebody got bought
a worn down skillet that was rusted.
And then they resurrected it.
They resurrected it
using those techniques.
Because the good stuff's under there.
It doesn't go away, it
just gets added stuff.
Because I just watch
cleaning stuff, you know,
on TikTok and on Instagram.
So that came up for me.
And then I don't know how it happened,
but we had a cast iron skillet
that I think I used on the grill.
Yeah.
To like saute onions to go
with like smash burgers.
And then I left it out
there and it got rust.
I've done this.
And I was really dejected.
And so I don't know which happened first,
but yeah, I used the sea
salt and you also use,
you put oil on it, you have to oil the-
When you're done, you oil
it and heat it up again
and then wipe that down.
So you want it to be really
oiled when you're done with it.
And you can kind of store it with some oil
so that it like-
Yeah.
You know, so it's like coated in oil
so it stays sealed and seasoned.
I just, honestly, I just leave,
we leave both the big one and
the small one on the stove
at all times.
We don't really have a place to put it up.
So it's just like, that's what we cook in
and it's there all the time.
Let's promote something.
Okay, what are we promoting?
We're still good.
You know the game that we
created along with Spin Master
that many of you have already played
and many of you have been
talking about the good times
you've been having with
family and friends playing.
It's a party game.
Party game,
'We're Still Good'
It's a nice little box
that you can take in your
luggage to wherever you're going.
For the holidays it's a great gift.
It's also a great thing
to play with your family
because it takes hilariously
ridiculous disasters
that everyone helps create
and then everyone helps
pitch the best positive spin
on that to say we're still good.
So it kind of, it's just
an injection of positivity
into your family or friend gatherings.
I think I'm gonna play it
with my extended family
over the holidays.
You should dude.
Is it weird to play a game
that has a picture of you on it?
Well, it's a cartoon picture of you
and maybe they won't notice.
Okay.
But here's the big update.
It's now available at mythical.com.
Yeah, it's been at Walmart,
it's been on Amazon
and you can still get it in those places.
But now you can also
get it at mythical.com
if you're already filling
your holiday cart over there.
Yes.
And you definitely should.
And you can get like points and stuff.
We're doing like, you know,
you can get points I think-
Oh really?
Over at mythical.com now.
So maybe, I don't know.
Either we are or we're going to.
Alright, my next thing.
Recent purchase.
Beringer Zenex 302 USB
premiere five input mixer
with Zenex Mic Preamp
and USB audio interface.
Two other things to go with this
so you can try to guess what I'm doing.
Day better.
50 50 RGB LED light strips.
Kit work with Alexa and Google Assistant.
Smart Wifi LED strip
lights, a hundred foot.
Two rolls of 50 foot LED
lights for bedroom decoration.
And finally, standard XLR male to female,
like the sound of that,
balanced microphone cable,
durable and flexible noise
canceling, six feet, black.
I mean this is clearly EHSB stuff.
Haha, E, I've never said EHSB.
Yeah, that was right.
Elk Hound Snuggle Baby.
That's right.
Are you gonna try to,
are you doing something
in your bedroom though?
Because there was a bedroom light thing.
Bedroom light was one of the descriptors.
Bedroom decoration.
So you gonna be DJing for your wife?
Are you trying to incorporate
the Elkhound into love making?
I'm setting up, you know
how our bedroom is big.
It has a whole seating area
at the foot of the bed.
Yeah, I would say unnecessarily large.
I know, but it's a function
of the space underneath it
that then created a bedroom above it
that was just so big.
We could have a party up there.
Party for two.
So, so.
Okay.
Party, you know, your
table's ready, party of two.
I'm setting up a DJ-
Practice area?
A DJ console set right
there facing the bed.
And it's gonna have lights,
it's gonna have visuals.
They're potentially going
to time out with the music
that I'm playing.
So yeah, I'm gonna be doing DJ sets.
I'm a be going Snugglebaby
mode right there.
No.
And I'm lying about part of this.
So that can't be the case.
No.
Your wife wouldn't let you
do that in the bedroom.
She wouldn't let you put
your practice facility
in the bedroom.
Yeah, I'm gonna set it
up at the Creative House
and the thing that I've,
I don't want to commit to
this but I bought this stuff,
which is trying to get me to commit to it.
I was listening to John Frusciante,
guitarist for the Red Hot Chili Peppers
talking to Rick Rubin.
You know, I got a thing for Rick Rubin
and anything he does in podcast world
and you're talking about
great series of interviews
where they talk about the production
of their last two albums
and Frusciante, if you're
really into guitar stuff,
you probably already like John Frusciante,
but he talks about his practice method
and then he gets his guitar down
and he demonstrates how he warms up
and he talked about his
philosophy of practice
as its own art form.
Like he doesn't practice
what he's gonna play on stage
when he tours.
He doesn't get really good at that
because he's improvisational.
All of his guitar solos are
just off the top of the dome.
So it's very much about him
just developing his skills
for hours before every show.
And he's amazing.
You know, it seems cool to like,
someone who's as amazing as he is
that puts that much work into it.
But it really stuck with
me when he talked about,
he saw practice as its own art form.
He invented ways to engage
in a totally different mode
than how he performs.
And then it subconsciously bleeds in
and makes him a better performer.
And I was like, you know what?
I bet you there's
something to that for me.
You know, cause I need to
practice my DJing more.
But I love an audience.
When the Sunbeam Furniture
place opened, you know,
that Jesse decorated
and Christie helped her
and did the plant stuff.
For that event they had
a DJ which was not me,
but I talked to that DJ.
She was super nice
and she talked about how over
the course of the pandemic,
along with a lot of DJs she
started Twitch streaming
and so I'm putting those
two things together
and my idea is to not just
practice but to stream it.
Oh, I like this.
I'm not, you know, just to create.
Yeah, cause if I'm gonna practice,
I might as well have an audience.
You know, I think that would motivate me.
And you can stream any other songs?
It doesn't like-
That's my understanding, yeah.
They don't employ the technology
that Instagram employs
that they'll take down your stream.
So it's a squirrly area, but
yeah, that's where DJ's stream,
unless something's changed
in the last month or so,
and then my hopes will be dashed
and then I could just do a muted stream
where you can watch me
but not hear me DJing.
But I'm just trying to develop
it as not a performance,
but a practice as an art form
that if anybody cares to be a
part of it, it'll be streamed.
You know, so it's gonna be very low key.
I'm excited about that.
But I wanna set it up
at the Creative House
cause that way I can just
kind of step into it and do it
but ultimately it's just
so I can practice more.
So I just went on one blog
and they said this is all
the stuff I needed to buy.
And I was like, I'm not
gonna overthink this.
I'm just gonna buy this crap
and I'm gonna set it up.
So that's my intention.
I'm putting it out there.
Somebody on Twitch-
Do you have a handle that-
Somebody parked Elkhound
Snugglebaby already.
But I have to believe it was a fan.
So reach out to me if
you're the one who parked
Elkhound Snugglebaby on
Twitch, reach out to me.
Well, you can reach out to them too.
I couldn't see how to do that on Twitch.
So right now it's Link
underscore Elkhound Snugglebaby.
Well, so it's gonna be one of those.
It's gonna be one of those.
I don't know when I'll do it, but I will.
Where are you setting it up at?
I'll tweet it out.
I thought I would set it up where,
I guess I need to get
your approval of this
since we're we're equal on this.
Not in my office.
So I was thinking like, you
know where the records are
and the record player is
like where that couch is.
If I could just rotate that couch out
and then the backdrop
could be those records
and apparently some LED lighting.
So you have to set it
up every time you do it?
I don't know.
That's kind of what I
was thinking that then
I would just move the-
Maybe the table can live right behind it.
I don't know.
There's probably room by there.
Okay. Mine's a little simpler.
If not, I could do it in my office.
My next one's a little simpler.
The Red Devil Venom mouth guard.
Why would you need a mouth guard?
Again, another revelatory
thing that I learned
that I figured out all on my own.
Okay.
Okay, so.
Meaning you didn't listen to a podcast?
No, this is just a
observation about myself
based on things that people
have been telling me.
So I've been going to, you know,
since the pandemic started winding down
and we started going back to the dentist,
one of my most recent
trips to the dentist-
Oh.
Was actually after we had
eaten that crazy sour thing
on the Vanity Fair or whatever that was.
That thing we shot where
we ate that sour candy
that was straight malach acid.
And they were like, no one
has ever kept the candy
in their mouths nearly
as long as you guys did.
We didn't expect you to keep
going and going and going,
but you know that's what we're gonna do.
We're us, man. We're freaking us.
And I actually think
I did permanent damage
to my enamel on my teeth.
I know, we were both scared.
And they noticed that.
And when I'm scared, I
don't think about it.
Like, something's wrong with my teeth,
I'm not gonna think about this anymore.
And it happened to you too and
you did the exact opposite.
I took action.
You took action.
So I ended up getting some
enamel repair toothpaste or whatever.
But one of the things that
the dentist pointed out was,
she was like, well the hygienist was like,
she legitimately asked me,
did you get your teeth shaved down?
What? Like what?
Like for some sort of like,
you mean for like, a
religious ritual or something?
She was like, your incisors
look like they're flat,
they're not pointed.
Do you see that?
They're not-
Yeah.
Like your dog teeth, right?
Like your eye teeth they call 'em.
Yours are pointed and
mine used to be pointed.
Mine are very pointed.
And so they were like,
well you're obviously
grinding your teeth at night.
So I went through the whole thing
of getting the mouth guard at night,
which I now have and which I do wear.
But I was like, I don't think
I grind my teeth at night,
but you don't really
know cause you're asleep.
And then I started realizing
that every time in my
life for the past 45 years
in which I have been
doing something intensely,
I grit up my teeth like this.
I've put my lower teeth
over my upper teeth,
my bottom teeth come out.
My dad does the same thing.
It's just like this.
So like, if any sports moment in my life,
you'll see it even when
I like throw a dart
on Good Mythical Morning like-
I do.
Oh wow.
And I've just been doing this all my life
and I do it when I lift weights
and I've been doing it when
I lift weights forever.
And I started reading about people
who do weird things with their
teeth when they lift weights
and I've been damaging my teeth for years.
And in fact, last time
I went to the dentist,
she was pointing at those teeth
and she was like, you're basically down
to the pulp on those teeth.
Like you don't have anything else left
protecting those teeth.
So I'm probably gonna have to
get like crowns or something,
like fake teeth at some point in my life.
I know a guy.
But in the meantime, of course,
anyone who seriously, and I
don't seriously lift weights,
I just lift weights for
ongoing health, you know.
Oh, so I thought you would say
you were gonna sleep with it.
No.
You lift weights with a mouth guard.
I have a sleeping mouth guard,
which is a completely different thing.
This is like an athletic mouth guard
that like Steph Curry wears
when he plays basketball.
And so because biting down
when you're lifting weights
is actually like scientifically proven
to give you a certain
percentage increase in strength
just because it's
something about, you know-
And which totally makes sense
because that's why when you're really
trying to do something, you bite down
and I would bite down like,
and I've been just ripping
these teeth apart for years.
So anyway, I've stopped the damage now
and I work out with a mouth guard.
And I encourage you if you
lift weights on a regular basis
or do anything physically active.
That's interesting.
Get a mouth card. You might as well.
Cherry pig.
Solar mole repellent,
ultrasonic mole repellent,
solar powered, outdoor waterproof,
ultrasonic snake repellent,
for get rid of mole,
gopher snakes, vole and
other underground pest.
Four pack.
Pretty obvious, right?
I'm actually surprised that
it says snake repellent.
I love that. So I got four of these-
I had some of these and
I got rid of my moles
in my yard, not on my skin.
Yeah, right. Yeah, yeah.
Some people have bought mole repellent
thinking that they can
rub it on themselves.
Yeah. This is like a steak
that you put in the ground.
It's got a little solar
panel thing on top.
I bought 'em, the moles went
away, my yard got even again.
And then somehow they disappeared.
They might be under Lincoln's bed
with a nest full of spoons. I don't know.
But I had to buy four more.
It's not poison, it's just a sound.
So I put, I steaked it out and
yeah, it works like a charm.
It forces them into my
neighbor's yard, underground.
But yeah, that's their problem.
Do you know that for a fact?
You seen evidence?
Based on the reviews.
Yeah, people describe how
if you do it in one area,
then they'll just move to another area.
And so the only area
for them to move in here
is my neighbor's yard.
I mean, maybe they went
all the way into the woods.
I don't know.
I don't care.
But I mean, I think that my neighbors
were probably sending 'em into my yard.
Everybody's gotta work together on this.
Everybody's gotta work together.
The only thing I don't like
is that it's not a constant.
So it's silence and then it's eeee.
Eeee.
So every time I would go outside
it was kind of unsettling.
You can hear it?
Yeah. Yeah.
It's gotta be like that though because-
It's not ultrasonic.
Well it says ultrasonic.
It's not freaking ultrasonic.
I would just call it sonic
because I can hear it.
It has to cut on and off
because otherwise they would adjust to it.
Potentially.
I don't know.
That's a good theory.
That's what I bought.
It does work, but then after
a while I get annoyed with it
and I take 'em up and then eventually,
it took about nine months
for 'em to come back
and maybe it was seasonal,
but the moles, voles or
whatever they are came back.
So I recommend that.
You're not killing 'em,
you're just shooing them.
Makes you feel a little better about it.
Well you could find a way
to catch 'em and eat 'em.
I'm not that hungry.
You could probably find
some recipes on TikTok
for mole stew or something.
Put 'em in that nicely oiled skillet.
This purchase comes with a story.
I bought four items, two
Carolina Panthers hats
and two Carolina Panthers shirts.
I remember seeing you wearing this once
and it was just one of those
things where it's like-
You didn't ask any questions.
I thought I told you this.
So-
Is this a James And The Shame?
Yes.
So I had a PR person working on
right around the launch
of the album with me
on some press opportunities.
And one of them was, I
guess it was Spin Magazine.
It has this thing where they
do musicians give predictions
for their favorite team's NFL season.
And she was like, would you be interested?
Do you watch NFL?
Do you have a favorite team
and would you be willing to do this?
And I was like, yes.
A little bit.
And then to the second question,
I mean I'm an NC State football fan,
I like college football
and that's what I watch.
But I consider myself a Rams
fan being in Los Angeles.
But I have a, you know,
an affinity for the Carolina Panthers
only because they're in North Carolina.
But I don't really keep up with it
and I don't own any fan gear.
So what I said is, yes, I'm willing to do-
You can't say that.
Yes, I'm willing to do this
and I can do either the
Rams or the Panthers.
I feel like there's probably somebody else
already representing the Rams, so yes.
And I'm like, the reason I'm doing this
is because of the press opportunity.
So I did it.
It's all an illusion.
So the first thing I needed to do was
you know, get clothes.
I don't, I mean I don't
even wear NC States-
Cause they were putting a picture of you?
Yeah, they wanted a picture
of me in Ram's gear.
I mean in Carolina Panther's gear.
So I had to find some.
Well based on what I saw
of you wearing that stuff,
I don't know if it's a
great PR opportunity.
I'm just telling you, I mean,
you looked like a dork dude.
Well, can I just say,
and I hate to say this,
but it's very difficult to
dress up in support of your team
and not look like a dork.
I know.
And I gotta-
It's like you're cosplaying
as what everyone thinks a fan is.
Aren't there people who are fans of sports
that also like to look cool?
You can, for some reason-
I have a theory. This is it.
They make the stuff out
of the same material
that they make athletic
clothing out of a lot of times.
So these t-shirts had this
moisture wicking dry fit.
So much of this stuff has this-
In case you need to go out there.
Well these people are
just watching sports guys.
On the field.
Like when you go watch a concert,
you can get a cool t-shirt
that is like a cotton t-shirt
or like a 50 50 t-shirt.
You can get a cool hat
that looks like someone who
is ready to watch something.
Fans of athletic performances
should be able to wear the same things
that fans of musical performances wear.
You're not playing.
Hey, hey, you need to shut up.
This is a business opportunity.
We need to keep this to ourself
till we're ready to launch.
They just don't make any cool,
they don't make enough cool stuff.
Even I would wear more
NC State stuff. I would.
It is just like a needle in a haystack
to find a shirt that's cool.
The retro logoing is one
particular avenue to coolness.
Even when they brought back.
Well NC State hasn't-
They brought that back.
Yeah, they brought back the wolf,
but then the stuff that they put it on,
it's like they're still
in this athletic mode.
What do you guys think I'm doing?
I'm sitting on a couch and
then standing up at moments
and then sitting back down on the couch.
I don't need
moisture wicking material here
And now posing for a photo
for Spin Magazine.
So what did you look,
I never saw this photo.
Did it happen?
Oh yeah, it was just a
selfie. I took it in there.
You were wearing what? A jersey?
No, I wore a T-shirt and a hat.
But even that still felt like,
this doesn't feel like me.
But I mean that's what they wanted.
The other piece of this puzzle is
I had to come up with my prediction
for the Carolina Panther season.
So at that point I just texted my dad
and said, "Dad, a
research project for you,
newly retired man."
Who also doesn't care that
much about NFL football,
but likes college football in Georgia.
He quickly like just came back with-
He's your ghost writer.
Here's what I think.
And now I will say that
if you read the article,
any funny parts of it-
Your dad wrote.
I wrote, because my dad
didn't make it funny.
It was very much just,
here's bullet points,
including my obsession
with the long snapper.
I added that.
Okay.
So the long snapper stuff
because I am genuinely
interested in long snappers
and the Johansen, I think his name is,
played 16 seasons without
missing a game or something.
Anyway, so yeah,
if you ever need any
Carolina Panthers stuff,
I got two hats and two shirts.
We could go out together.
That you will never wear again.
Yeah, also, I'm kind of-
Did anything come from it?
Did you get any listens
from Caroline Panthers fans
that you're now completely
undermining with this story?
Well, I think the name of the article was
56 Musicians Predict Their
Take on their NFL season.
Who else?
Some people that you would recognize
and a lot of people that you wouldn't.
So maybe I got one listen from that.
It was worth it.
That's the world of PR man.
Oh yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Here's a good one, sweet one.
Where the Sidewalk Ends, the book.
I'm familiar with it.
Shell Silverstein and
I didn't write it down,
but also we got a bunch of
our favorite, you know, kids-
Kids' books.
A couple of Shell Silversteins,
like the Light in the Attic,
Where the Wild Things Are.
And this was-
Did you get the issue of Playboy
with his famous interview?
Did you also get that?
Uh uh, uh uh.
That would've been a nice touch.
Yeah Shell Silverstein.
He wrote a boy named Sue for Johnny Cash.
He's was in that world,
the outlaw country world.
Anyway, but cool thing.
This was in honor of-
Maybe you've seen these,
if you take a walk with
your dog in a neighborhood
or if you go to certain parts of town,
you can see there's
these little libraries.
They look like a bird box.
But it's a library where
you can exchange books.
You can put a book in, take a book out.
And Christie did this with,
well, her sister Britney
and JB, they ordered
and then her dad, Bobby, my father-in-law
built one of these boxes
and then they painted it custom color
and they put the plaque on it
and they put it up in
honor of their, you know,
their first daughter passed away
hours after being born.
And she would've been 10 years old,
Sayla would've been 10
years old this year.
So every year they celebrate her life
and then their other kids,
they now have two more kids.
I got a niece and a nephew.
They, you know, they learn about Sayla
and the story of, even
through all of that pain
that it's become something
that's been very beautiful,
you know, in honoring her memory.
So for her 10th birthday, they
created one of these boxes.
So we were able to buy book books for it
and we were actually-
Did they put it up in the neighborhood
or did they put it up in
front of their house or?
They put it up in
Lilington at the ballpark,
you know where you and
I did the 4th of July.
Where they do the fireworks every year.
That's where I played
baseball hundreds of time.
And where we did our 4th of
July Wax Paper Dogs concert.
Yeah, they actually put it up there.
And because we went back
for Lance's wedding,
we were there for the ribbon cutting.
So we were able to put the books in there
and honor Sayla's life and memory
and it was a great family
moment to be a part of that.
And yeah, I wrote down the name of the...
littlefreelibrary.org.
Oh. So you can just make one?
There's a number of places
If you register it?
That will do it.
But if you go to little free library.org,
you can order the pieces
and they'll send it to you
and you can build it
and paint it yourself.
And then they'll send you
like the plaque to put on it
so that in their case it can say
'In honor of Sayla'.
And then, you know, it
is part of the community
and it looks really cool and nice
and of course they got
permission from the ballpark
to put it there.
That's awesome.
So yeah, littlefreelibrary.org,
and you can do it for
whatever reason you want
or just do it to contribute
to your community.
But there's lots of kids
who are taking walks
or like, "Hey, let's go to that library.
Let's see what books are in there now.
Let's put some of my
favorite books in there."
You think kids are doing that?
Yeah, definitely.
Kids still got books?
Yeah, that's the thing.
It's kind of this retro thing
that gives you a sense of connection
and being a part of
something in real life.
Unless you vandalize it.
Yeah, I mean this is
in a good place where-
It only takes one.
Yeah. Sadly that's true.
When you talk about that place,
the Lilington ball fields there.
Yeah.
They're so nostalgic to
me because of the smell,
which it was a mix of dirt, grass, popcorn
and cigarette smoke that I
felt like I smelled repeatedly
as a child playing outdoor sports
that was so pronounced at
that particular location
that I'm sure it doesn't smell as much
like cigarette smoke anymore
because it's just so much less
common for people to smoke.
Well the other cool part
of it was that morning,
our nephew Nehemiah,
he had a soccer game there on the field.
So we watched him play and
then we dedicated the library,
took some pictures, but I was like,
yeah, it's wild to come back here.
I was telling, you know,
telling Lincoln Orlando,
I played T-ball on these fields,
but you know, because I hated T-ball.
It makes you feel anxious
when you see the fields?
Yeah. I was like, my butt
hole was getting real tight.
So yeah, I choose to think more
about all of the fireworks.
That's what I associate
with the fireworks.
We do fireworks here.
Fireworks every year.
Okay, here's the next one from me.
Five pack USB wall charger
and five pack charger cables.
Oh yeah.
This has to be an annual re-up.
I just feel like, again, I don't want to,
I'm gonna go into the dad mode.
So the thing I have asked for is,
so I have a charger next to my bed right?
For my phone.
It is a wireless charger
that I can set my phone on
and I can also put my AirPods on
and they can both charge.
And then Jesse uses a
traditional just USB cable
that plugs directly into her phone.
That's a shame.
Which makes her a prime
target for Shepherd
when he needs a phone charger.
And because he is a 14 year old.
Yep.
Apparently they eat these things.
What is it?
I believe that that's what's happening.
It's spoons, it's cables.
I think that Shepherd is eating the cables
thinking that they're pasta
maybe getting into a
late night kind of thing.
I don't know he gets confused.
This is such a pattern.
If we took him to get his stomach X-rayed,
there would be like 17
USB cables in there.
That's the only explanation
for how many of these we go through.
And so instead of-
You might as well just put
it on a monthly reorder.
Well, here's what I did.
I spent months admonishing him
and then Jesse would get mad
because he would take her charger
and then she would need to use my charger
and the domino effect.
And so I just said,
instead of having this repeated argument,
which we have about USB cables and socks.
We have the sock argument,
because I have two boys
who wear the same socks
as me and we share socks.
Yes.
I'm just giving-
So I regularly buy socks
and again, I think he may-
I know
He may be
eating socks as well.
But I just said I'm gonna
have every room you go in,
there's gonna be a place
to charge your phone.
Oh.
Cables.
It's like everywhere.
Somewhere there's a charger.
Let me just say that I
actually did this purchase
twice this year.
So there was 10 cables and 10 USB chargers
and we still do not have enough.
Yep, yep.
Nope, it's not gonna work.
It's not gonna work.
It has to be hardwired.
You have to screw 'em in.
It has to become a fixture.
Oh, that's not a bad idea.
Yep. You gotta like, you gotta sit there
and you gotta screw it against the wall.
He'll find a way.
He'll find a way to eat them.
He'll gnaw it loose.
Lube life, water-based personal
lubricant for men and women.
Flavorless. 12 ounce.
Yep.
I purchased that.
Now I will say, Lube
Life is a weird brand.
It was very highly rated
and it was like the top of
the list needed to re-up on,
you know, my lube.
And I didn't realize how big 12 ounces is
when it comes to lube.
Like this is a big, I mean-
It's like a can of coke.
Well it-
But then if it's thinner
it's probably this tall.
Yeah.
It's a little less than half
the diameter of a can of Coke.
So it's twice as tall as a can of Coke.
Can you get it in your ass?
Has that worked yet?
Oh God.
I can't get it in the bedside drawer.
Okay. So yeah, first you
get it in the drawer.
That's the problem. That's the problem.
Then you start working on your ass.
Just a word of advice.
When it comes to lube, smaller's better,
you know, ironically.
Yeah.
Because in the moment of passion,
you don't wanna pull it out.
You want to be a little bit coy about it.
Yeah. Here I am getting up
and running into the bathroom.
Because we have one drawer
that it can sit straight up.
Cause you don't wanna store it sideways.
And you've already got a
hydro flask in one hand
when you're making love.
Right.
So you can't have another giant container.
No hands with it.
Yeah, exactly.
And plus, their marketing is strange.
The bottle, it doesn't just say lube life,
it says hashtag lube life.
Like they expect people to
be sharing this stuff public.
Well you are now.
I guess I am.
And you just said it, so.
Hashtag lube life.
So it worked.
That's my resolution.
Every tweet I make in in 2023
is gonna have that hashtag.
Yeah. I don't-
Pay attention to the ounces y'all.
I don't get it from Amazon.
There's some other website
that I got in my lube from this year.
Can't remember what it was.
You know when Sex with Emily
podcast sent us the gifts,
there was an appropriately
sized lube there
that was more drawer sized.
Been using that.
You can refill it with the big one.
And I can refill it from the big one.
Just don't let anybody see you do that.
I gotta get a lube funnel now.
Okay. I'm gonna skip over a few here
since I don't want this to take forever.
60 pieces, painted figures.
60 piece. Okay.
What is this?
I think this is an interesting
way to talk a little bit
about our approach to
things maybe in 2023.
Oh.
So...
You talking about TikTok?
Well, I bought 60 little figurines
that you would use if you were making-
Train sets?
If you were a train person
and you did toy train models and stuff
and you created a little town
or a Christmas village
or something like that.
And my idea at the time was
to buy some of these figurines
and then write sketches that
featured these figurines
very, very small.
I mean very close up, you know,
kind of like Robot
Chicken-ish sort of thing.
But ridiculous situations
where you would take
the specific figurines
that you had in this set-
And make a story.
And make a story based on kind of
what was suggested to you by this set.
Kind of an old school idea.
Very much an idea that I've
had for even 20 years ago,
back in the very early
days of us, you know,
the Fein brothers used to do
some stuff with figurines,
way, way back in the day that
ended up getting in trouble
because they were doing actual
Action figures.
You know, recognizable
IP, but this is different.
And that was when we were in our,
what are we doing on TikTok and,
are we doing an original strategy?
Are we doing original sketches?
And you know, if you've watched our TikTok
and our short form Instagram stuff,
we've done a bunch of different things
trying to land on a strategy.
Incidentally, the strategy
that we have landed on
at least right now is that
we do so much other stuff
that generates great
moments and funny things
that we say and do that
we should just use those
to fuel our TikTok.
So that's why if you go
on the TikTok right now,
you see it's just all GMM clips, right?
But one of the things
that we did before that.
And I like that. I like that.
And we'll talk about how we're using that,
the freed up mind space,
time and energy that we have
by not trying to make
original sketches on TikTok
and what that means for
what we're gonna do.
Because we are gonna put
that energy to something
that you will be seeing.
But we did make a sketch
that I still think it-
We should put it out.
I still think we should put it out,
especially in light of this conversation.
Yeah, we gave notes on it twice.
We need to-
And we rerecorded the VO
cause we didn't really like
the VO that we did the first time.
And it's ridiculous.
It's a ridiculous thing
that we still should just put on TikTok.
And you have those figurines on your desk
at the Creative House.
The Creative House.
So now at least you have some decor too.
And I like to play with,
I like to just hold them in my hands.
I feel like a giant
playing with little people
when I'm on a phone call.
But yeah, so just so you know, we are-
We're gonna release that.
We'll release that-
We'll release that.
But a lot of the energy
that we've been putting into
other things like that stuff
and stuff that you may not have seen,
we are finding ways in
2023 to funnel that energy
into things that you will see.
We'll talk more about that
in 2023 in another podcast.
But just so you know
what you're not seeing
in original content on TikTok,
you will be seeing in other places soon.
I will quickly mention
Nature's Miracle Advanced Stain
and Odor Eliminator, 32 Ounce.
Oh, I got one of those.
Now when it comes to-
The red bottle?
Mine was a different brand,
but it was on my list.
I took it off.
Yeah, well cause it's the
thing I said at the top
about trying to not get my dogs to sneak
and poop in the house is very difficult.
And it's really just
a Jasper issue, right?
Well yes, definitely a lot more.
Jade will not pee in the house.
But Jasper, we had a
lot of problem with him
peeing in the house and
that's why contrary to lube,
32 ounce is the minimum you
want for something like this.
Right.
I mean, we had to take the rug out
from under our dining
room table completely.
When we were trying to train him
and really getting serious about it.
Cause once they start peeing in a spot-
They go back.
They go back to that spot.
So we're not 100% out of the woods.
But he's made tremendous progress.
A lot of progress this year with Jasper,
going on walks, I've done
a lot of training with him.
He doesn't bark at other
people on walks anymore.
My treat game is on lock.
And he's very motivated,
so I'm really proud of him.
And then at home he's
just gotten a lot better.
You know, he's over two years old now
and I think he's finally getting there.
And it took Jade that long too.
I've heard that it's a Datsun thing.
Housebreaking.
But I just wanted to give an
honorable mention to that.
I'll also give an honorable mention to
broom and dust pan set with long handle.
Kitchen brooms and standup
dust pan magic combo set.
Magic combo set for home.
Lobby broom with rotation head
and standing dust pan for floor cleaning.
Red.
Very excited about this.
I replaced my broom.
You don't look as
riveted as you should be.
Well, I made a purchase about dog piss too
and so I was gonna try
to slip that in there,
but then you moved on to a broom.
Yeah, it's too late.
Well, no, mine's way better than yours,
so I'm gonna go back to it.
Okay, cool.
The broom.
Well, first let's talk about a broom.
Yeah. Right.
Well it's not the broom,
it's the dust pan.
The dust pan has its own handle.
The previous dust pan I had,
it would stick to the handle of the broom
and it became a unit so
they could stay together.
But now I've upgraded to a
dust pan with its own handle.
Tall handle.
And the broom and so
there's no bending over
and it's just beautiful.
I feel like one of those
people at Disneyland
who just walks around cleaning up-
The moment you drop something
at Disneyland, whew.
There's somebody there sweeping it up.
You know, I do that in my house now.
Somebody dropped something, I
sweep it up and then here's-
You can stream that on Twitch.
Here's the, yes, here's
the revolutionary part.
There are teeths coming
off of the dust pan
so that when I sweep it,
then I can put the broom
bristles into the teeth
and then move in a vertical motion.
So it's an L motion and
it cleans the broom.
The broom itself.
And this is something that should,
it's just revo-freaking-lutionary.
If you have a dust pan that
doesn't have his own handle,
and it doesn't have a bristle
cleaner on the dust pan,
you must upgrade immediately.
You're welcome.
Okay, it's the first thing
I'm gonna do after this
is I'm gonna make that purchase.
Don't, you know what, that's
what I'm gonna give you
and everybody else I love for Christmas.
Okay.
Spoiler alert.
The only time my sweep
is when somebody makes,
like there's an accident.
I feel like the rest
is handled via vacuum.
Or dog.
Yeah.
Back to dogs though, because as you know,
similar struggles with Sean.
Sean has been-
Sean is a problem, dude.
Sean is false advertising.
I talked to you about this before
when they said he was a little anxious
and he was house trained.
He's very anxious and he was
not house trained at all.
Well I freaking came into the-
like two weeks ago, I come
into the freaking office
and Sean's there and
he's just barking at me.
And I was like, the best
thing I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna ignore him.
I'm not gonna give him the time of day.
I'm gonna walk on my desk.
So I take a step by him
and the dude freaking
bites me on the calf twice.
Yeah.
I was wearing sweatpants.
Well that's the one aspect of his training
that is going well.
The training to hate you.
Is the only thing that he's
responding to right now.
No, the interesting
thing was I had on a hat
and you said, I think he has
an issue with people with hats.
Well our friend Jayden, when he is in town
has been staying at my place
and he's a great dog trainer.
One night he said,
I think Sean has a thing with hats
because if somebody that he actually knows
comes in with a hat on-
So maybe in his former life-
We don't know what happened
to him in his former life,
but things happened to Sean.
Yeah. Poor boy.
But he is getting better.
I took the hat off and
he did seem to chill out.
Yeah. So we've gotta figure that out.
That whole thing of biting
people is obviously a big no-no.
Essentially if somebody's entering a room,
he has to either be, he has to be held
or he has to be on a leash
and then he calms down.
But the thing that he's doing
that is a constant struggle
is pissing and shitting in the house.
And we talk to our trainer about that.
Now he will find a spot,
and he'll have a shit spot for two weeks
and then it'll shift.
The shit spot shifts.
Yeah.
To somewhere else.
And he is better about not pissing inside,
but what we were doing,
we don't have any real grass outside.
Peeing inside is much worse.
Is much worse.
So he has curbed that a little bit.
But we were talking to
the trainer we were like,
I just don't know if
we have the discipline
and the amount of commitment
and time that it takes
to really do this in the right way.
Give us some help.
So will you live with us?
And the trainer said,
because he had become scared
of the fake grass outside,
which is our only grass.
I don't know, I would love
to get inside Sean's head,
but I know one thing I would find there
is nightmarish fake grass.
Apparently somebody
with a hat took him out
onto some fake grass and
did some ungodly things
to him in his past life,
because he doesn't like
either one of those things.
Oh, poor guy.
But he's adjusting very, very well,
for somebody of his past.
Jasper was the same way.
Yeah. He's totally a different dog now.
There's some stuff called fresh patch,
which is just a patch of fresh grass
most often used for people
who live in apartments
and they want their dog to
use the bathroom on grass
and you don't wanna always have to
take 'em outside or whatever.
So essentially it's just a piece of sod
that comes in a cardboard box.
Shipped to your door.
Every two weeks, you get it. Right?
First of all, I think
it's 60 bucks a month.
So I know that it's
significantly more expensive
than if I was just going-
cause I told Stevie about this
and she was like, you could
just go to the hardware store
and get a patch of grass
for a lot cheaper than that.
And I was like, yep.
But I'd have to go get it.
Yeah, yeah.
You're not proud of it, but-
I'm not proud of it.
Yeah, you're doing it.
So let me tell you, it works.
Oh, so now you're excited about it?
It works.
And he immediately-
It's not in the house?
It's outside on top of
the artificial grass.
No, it's outside on top
of the concrete area.
Cause it's closer to the door.
Okay.
And he immediately went
out there and got on it
and started using it.
Something clicked.
He was like, this is what's
supposed to happen on this.
And then if it's raining, I take it
and I move it to the
other side of the house
that has a covering over
there on the pool side.
Yeah.
And he goes out there
and he uses it on that.
The problem is, is that unlike Barbara
who would never pee or
crap in the house, ever,
like she is, Barbara is-
A superior dog.
She would just stay there for 24 hours.
Oh, I tell her that all the time.
How I love her so much more
because my love is conditional for dogs.
And until Sean gets his together,
I'm not gonna love him as much.
So, but he doesn't let you know.
Barbara goes to the door, rings the bell,
and then looks at you like, come on.
I did this. I'm ready.
Sean, a little stupid.
So he's rung the bell a couple of times.
But anyway, this fresh patch thing,
it's really been the answer to us
because Jesse's got all
these freaking rugs.
I mean, Christie's the same way.
They get these rugs that are nice rugs
and you then you got a
freaking dog pissing on 'em
and you can't spray that
typical cleaner on those rugs.
Like Jesse will not let me
put any sort of pet spray.
She's like soda water only.
Oh.
I mean, she'll break up a little LaCroix
and pour it right on one of those things.
But only soda water.
You can't put cleaner on it.
Look at the life you're leading.
Yeah I'm cleaning up things with LaCroix
and paying $60 a month-
Perriere.
For a patch of freaking grass.
I've already done my honorable
mentions, so I'm done.
Oh really?
Is there anything that you want to-
Yeah, I mean probably I
guess two really quickly,
including the most significant one.
So one of the things I did this year,
of course as it relates
to James and the Shame
is I had to look the part
in terms of my photo shoot
and album and promo stuff and-
Hipster cowboy.
Performance at Mythic Con
and that kind of thing.
And in an effort to continue
to separate James And The Shame
from whatever the Rhett
McLaughlin brand is,
I was like, I gotta adopt
some kind of look here.
I'm not a cowboy hat guy.
I didn't want do that, you know?
Yeah. I'm glad.
But it's funny because
the guys that I think
have the best style in
country music right now
is Midland, right?
Oh yeah.
And every picture you see
of those guys are like,
ah, that's cool.
They're cool, they're
cool, but it's country.
But it's cool.
It's a little fun, that's why I like it.
And I was talking with Brian our COO here.
Business Brian.
He knows everybody man.
That dude knows everybody.
And he ends up like, yeah,
my friend is their manager or something,
I can't remember the exact connection,
but he immediately comes back with
the brands that they wear.
Oh.
You know, if you're
looking for cool stuff.
So they wear a lot of stuff
and I'm sure they've
got stylists for days,
but H Bar C is cool Western wear,
Western shirts and stuff like that.
So a lot of the stuff I got
this year was from them.
And then, because I needed some boots
cause I just didn't have any boots.
But I didn't want to-
if you go to a Western store
and you get a pair of boots,
there's six or $700 for
a good pair of boots.
I'm like-
It's an art form.
I'm not doing anything in these things.
Nope.
Again, I'm not, this is like
unnecessary moisture wicking
in a Carolina Panthers t-shirt.
So I found the brand Tecovas.
Austin based, you know, this is happening.
People are coming in
and sort of revolutionizing an industry
and usually it's two guys who have an idea
who come together, like Thursday boots.
It's like, we're gonna make boots
but we're gonna make 'em more affordable
and our advertising is gonna be great
and you're gonna get this
on Instagram all the time
and eventually you're gonna
break down and buy 'em.
I think it's two guys
because you're a guy.
But I think there's
plenty of two women too.
Yeah, well I'm saying cause it's, yeah-
I'm just saying, I'm talking about
for the products that are-
For you.
For me and Tecovas is an example of this.
They're making good boots
that look just like the
really expensive boots
that are 250, 300 bucks for a pair,
which is a much more reasonable amount.
Anyways, so I've got a few pairs of those
that has kind of completed
the James and the Shame look
in the times when I've needed to do that.
Oh. So we're doing
doing apparel shoutouts.
I'll give an apparel
shoutout to Imperfects.
Okay. Is that like spanks?
California based.
It's a surf aesthetic company,
but it's a lot of canvas wear.
This jacket and all of the other ones.
This year for me has been
the two piece jumpsuit.
Oh, that's where you got all those from.
Revolution. Right.
Yeah. I'm obsessed with that brand.
Very cool aesthetic and their
story and their approach
and their craftsmanship.
Is it two guys?
As far as I can tell, it's just one dude.
Okay.
Who, I think he's a surfboard shaper.
At least a lot of the images are of a guy
wearing these outfits shaping surfboards.
Well maybe you can get into that too.
Nope.
And finally my biggest ticket item,
my birthday present to myself.
Something that I've wanted for a long time
and I tried to find ways to
get at it in a cheaper fashion
and I finally just bit the bullet,
literally took the plunge.
Oh.
And bought one of those
cold plunge ice baths
that were featured on Shark Tank.
But that was a birthday present, right?
To myself.
Yeah, but that was your birthday present.
My big ticket item last year
was my mountain bike I believe.
And it was my birthday present to myself.
Yeah.
But I mean it was the biggest
purchase of the year for me.
And you've used it
because I made everybody-
It's basically a bathtub
with a box beside it
that then circulates and
refrigerates the water
so that, but you need, it has
a top on it like a hot tub
would have on it.
But it's shaped like a bathtub.
Yeah and it's pretty, you know.
He has an outdoor refrigerated bathtub.
It's pretty aesthetic, you know,
for how these things could go.
Because what I was gonna
do is I was gonna do-
Aesthetic.
The cheaper version, which is to take,
again, there's a bunch of YouTube videos-
Like a barrel?
Well people do barrels with ice in 'em,
but then you have to get ice
and put it in every single day.
You don't know what the temperature is.
Other people will take an old freezer,
open top freezer and seal it
and then do this thing
where it's on a timer.
So it's not on when
you're in it and stuff,
but it's like a DIY thing
and you got a freezer outside.
And then I was like, why not man,
just get the one that looks the part
and it is got all the
technology built into it
and you can dial in the temperature.
It's got the ozone filtering
of the water in there.
So it keeps the water
great for six months.
And I've always wanted
this cause you know...
We know.
I'm that guy that is
gonna take the supplements
and we get real hot and get
real cold and do all that stuff.
You need things, you need the things.
And I absolutely love it.
Did you get into it this morning?
I did. I sure did.
I get into it every day.
So now you don't hate it, do you?
No, no, no, no.
That's the point.
The point is you hate it every time.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
You hate the moment-
But when you got me to
do it, I did hate it.
Especially the moment
right before you do it
every single day.
That decision.
Am I gonna do this today?
First of all, there's scientific evidence
for certain health benefits
or whatever, which are great.
That's not really the reason I'm doing it.
I'm doing it because it
makes you feel really good
because you get this burst
of, I guess it's serotonin
that lasts a few hours,
but I kind of go into this ritual
where it's that minute
before you get in there
is this sort of, I'm
gonna get into this thing
and it's gonna be very unpleasant.
Especially the moment of
making the decision to get in
and lower yourself into this thing.
Ooh yes.
Every day.
And right now I've got it at 51 degrees,
it goes down to 39 and
you're supposed to decrease
a degree a week.
I started at 55.
I'm gonna tell you right now.
Is that what I got in it at?
You got it at 55, which again,
you may not think that's cold-
55, I'm gonna tell you right now.
Get in 55 degree water.
If you don't think that's cold, dude.
Five to 10 minutes and you'll see,
I mean your body thinks that you're dying.
You're doing something
that's going to kill you
and that's why it responds
the way that it does.
Yeah.
But there's this, even this
morning when I was in there
hating it in the first 30 seconds,
I kind of open my hands up.
Cause again, opening your hands
under the surface of the water
makes you that much colder
because your hands are, I don't know,
can't remember the technical term for it.
Some sort of surface that
your heat escapes your hands,
you know, it degrees.
Quickly.
That's why covering, wearing gloves
actually does keep you warm.
But just sort of having this breathing
through the adversity,
which a lot of the people
who do it on regular basis
are like, that's kind of why they do it
because you develop this sort of
physiological response to adversity
and you breathe through it
and you learn to expect it and accept it
and kind of move through it
and sort of long term creates,
makes you more willing
to deal with adversity.
And so I'm doing it because
it makes me feel good.
Ironically that, well I
don't know if it's ironic,
but that's the thing
that kind of motivates me
to be interested in it.
So I do like that philosophically.
Yeah. And I think it really does have-
You might get up tomorrow
and find me in it.
It really does-
You can come over and
use it anytime you want.
It really does have sort of a euphoria
that happens right after,
cause I get out of it,
I put a robe on and then
go make my smoothie,
which is, you know, full of
olive oil and other things
and I'm freezing in that moment.
But oh man, I feel good.
Can you take footage of you doing this
so that we could see this happening?
That could probably be arranged.
I mean, I don't want a
close up or anything,
but just like-
I am naked inside of it.
Are you?
Most of the time.
We have guests right now,
so I'm not naked in there.
Just in case they come down
for breakfast or whatever.
Wore a little bathing suit this morning.
Okay, we'll do that for the video
or let's have some tasteful cropping.
Tasteful cropping.
Okay.
I don't think I had a big splurge.
Well, I think I bought my DJ deck,
I think that was this year.
It had to have been.
Yeah, for sure it was.
Okay well here we are.
It's my wreck.
Everything we've said
today is basically a wreck
in one form or another.
So, I'm gonna put it back
to the community birdhouse.
Littlefreelibrary.org.
Hmm.
Called it a birdhouse,
but you know what I mean.
Don't put birds in there,
put books in there.
Book house.
Hashtag ear biscuits.
We'll be back at you next week.
And remember, let us know what you think
by sending us your voice.
One-888
♪ Ear pod ♪
♪ One ♪
We got a couple, just two more episodes
before we wrap up the season.
Is that right?
Yep.
Yeah. So we're gonna talk a little bit
about our Thanksgiving break
and then we're gonna cover
our highlights for the year.
I love it. I love that one.
Bye-Bye.
What is up Rhett and Link.
This is Jacob from Dallas, Texas.
I also broke a collarbone
while mountain biking.
I broke both of my
collarbones at the same time.
Yeah. Healing process sucked.
It took three months for me to fully heal
and it hurts when it gets cold.
Thanks guys.
Link, I hope you're
all healed up properly.
Rhett, keep on growing out that hair boy.
Hi Rhett and Link.
This is Shane from Alvin, Texas
listening to the most recent podcast.
And I'd like to think that
I'm in the 90th percentile of whistlers.
Allow me to give you the
Kill Bill theme song.
Hope you enjoyed. Thanks.
I hope I am the first to say
congratulations on your
Streamy Show of the Year Award.
I'm kind of embarrassed to say
I only found y'all in 2019,
but since then y'all have become
by far my favorite YouTubers ever.
Ever.
Love you guys. Congratulations.
To watch more ear biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.